hey youtubers it's Charlie so this week
on arrow the streets were literally on
fire it was mass pandemonium we got a
lot of big plot threads that were tied
up and we got some images from the
finale so I also have news on the flash
TV show trailer they're gonna be airing
that pretty soon if you're finding me
for the first time I do arrow videos
every week along with you know Q day's
bonus videos once arrow goes off the air
I'll just start doing more bonus DC
videos so leave me suggestions for what
you want those to be and be sure to
subscribe to get them so real quick
about the flash TV show the rumor is is
that the trailer is going to air during
the arrow finale next week so you'd
better watch just to play it safe we're
also probably gonna find out when it's
going to premiere in the fall I would
expect September October you know around
the time season 3 of arrow premieres it
just makes sense that they would air
them back-to-back so careful for
spoilers from the episode if you haven't
seen it yet but here are my top five
moments number five Oliver has failed
this city
it was a nice twist on the line he had
to say it at some point Stephen Amell
even commented in a recent interview
that he hasn't said on the show in a
long time it's mostly a season one list
kind of thing speaking of which he also
said in a Q&A that he posted to Facebook
just the other day that the list would
be coming back soon it would be a thing
again pretty soon in the context of this
episode he was just talking about his
failure to kill Slade when he had the
chance because we don't know what went
down in that final fight on the Amazo
vote we'll just have to wait and see for
the finale but I would assume that what
happened is is that he shot him and
incapacitated him with that arrow that
he stole off the boat and then just
failed to follow up by chopping his head
off in case you were wondering based on
Merlyn taking down that super soldier
with the arrow I think all you have to
do to kill one is land a sufficient
headshot but if you want to be sure just
chop their heads off just imagine you're
a Winchester in Supernatural and you're
killing vampires just chop their heads
clean off and that should do it
number four Malcolm Merlyn returns we've
known he was coming back for a long time
but his entrance was so very Captain
Jack that I just cheered out loud on my
TV John Barrowman has this really
swashbuckler pirate charm there's just
so much fun to watch he's playing Merlyn
a very very bad person but did you see
the smile on his face when he said I'm
her father I think that was just John
Barrowman on set having a little bit of
fun he's trying to take Fiat to safety
but I love that he's still able to slip
some jokes in
while people are trying to bash him
against pylons trying to kill him I mean
that's just Captain Jack for you Thea
did have that line how are you still
alive
and even though I don't think it was a
reference to Torchwood I still kind of
took it that way
it was this interview that John
Barrowman did where he revealed that the
arrow producers explained Merlyn to him
as a stable villain as in like horses
stables meaning that they're gonna trot
him out every once in a while implying
that he would never truly die which is
great take that with a grain of salt but
there's also rumors that Merlyn could be
the season 3 big bad also I saw a lot of
you on Twitter commenting about Thea
making that gunshot at the end she
wasn't shooting Merlyn that was just a
fake out what I think happened is is the
mirakuru soldier got up behind Merlyn
and we just didn't see him and she was
shooting that person number 3
Slade watches Rome burn I love the Nero
reference he made I don't think Slade
would ever let anyone catch him singing
but I bet he was singing inside his head
or maybe that evil Tinkerbell shadow was
singing to him who else laugh though
when Isabel was like WTF is shado
remember she did that because it's gonna
come back in the finale just addressing
the fact that Slade is hallucinating
someone the big thing here is Slade
revealing his true plan for Starling
city you know literally just burning it
to the ground
brother blood even said the person you
loved most part of me wants to think
that he was talking about the city
itself as a person just because I don't
think that Oliver loves any of the women
on the show more than the others like he
loves his sister equally as much as he
loves felicity Sara and Laurel so the
women cancel each other out and by
default or go left with is the city so
let's go with that there's also a really
small chance that he could be talking
about all of her son but the episode
didn't address that number two Felicity
takes down Isabel who else feels like
this is building towards a Felicity
versus Isabel fight in the finale I love
the cut between scenes though her asking
Diggle where she was straight to
Felicity BAM ramming her with the band
interrogator Felicity to the rescue I
was a little bit confused as to why
Isabel hates Felicity so much
I mean Diggle is the one that killed her
and all of her father's the one that
throw away so let me know in the
comments below why does she hate
Felicity so much it might just be the
smug way Felicity treated her
you know mirakuru has a way of turning
insecure
people into Psychopaths I really love it
when they give us those types of
felicity scenes like normally she's
sitting into computer so it's so much
more rewarding to see her get to win a
physical fight like during the clocking
episode whenever she took that bullet
I'm just really hoping that she doesn't
have to take too many bullets during the
finale and my number one WTF moment
Amanda Waller is going to destroy
Starling city to save the rest of the
country I actually expected those
soldiers to be League of Assassins
people but you know facepalm of course
they wouldn't roll in like the cavalry
they would sneak in it's all Argost and
even though she said she was using a
drone strike to drop bombs don't be
surprised if the Suicide Squad shows up
I feel like any episode that Amanda
Waller shows up in is like a backdoor
Suicide Squad episode but it's too bad
that Harley Quinn is not on the team
because Streets of Fire really feels
like her kind of party at the end I
totally expect team arrow to pull off
the 11th hour save and avert the drone
strike and I also think that we'll end
up with a situation where it's like
everyone but Slade versus Slade even
Isabel kind of looks like she's seeing
him in a different light I really hope
that they do let Felicity land the kill
shot on her but I feel like she's gonna
need Nyssa and Sara's help to do it
Stephen Amell actually said this really
interesting thing about the finale he
was asked to describe it in three words
and he said wait he's where as in a
question I think he was referring to
Slade and Oliver just learning that he
was on the island even if it's not the
island it applies that Slade will end up
somewhere really unexpected like the
foundry but the foundry feels like it's
too predictable as one last bonus moment
I also have to talk about the death of
brother blood there are a few things
about his death that surprised me mostly
that Laurel didn't kill him and that it
happened in such a short amount of time
the show had been foreshadowing a
conflict within team Deathstroke for a
while like the idea that evil always
turns on itself but it feels like they
should have waited to the finale for
brother blood to try and help team arrow
so I think it was mostly because they
wanted to wake boy up at the beginning
of the finale but now it's your turn let
me know below in the comments what was
your favorite moment you know was it
Felicity hitting Isabel with the car was
it Oliver
you know twisting his you failed the
city line on himself you know wasn't
brother blood dying also here's a couple
really big plot points that the episode
didn't address a lot that I think are
gonna come back in the finale the
biggest one being all of her son you
obviously is that going to come back in
the finale and if it doesn't will you
all be pissed I'll be a little
disappointed it's such a huge reveal why
would they tease us with it so late in
the season if it wasn't gonna become a
critical part of the finale could the
baby be the person that Oliver loves the
most you know even though he doesn't
know about it slate could just be
assuming that if Oliver knew about it
would be his greatest treasure
then there's the League of Assassins we
know they're coming back we saw the
image of Nyssa but whenever Sara
explains why she came back she says
nothing about bringing friends back with
her so either Sara doesn't know they're
coming or the writers just wanted it to
be more of a surprise and then there's
the relationship between team arrow and
the police force clearly Quentin's
lieutenant goes along with team arrow
helping just because of all the super
soldiers but will that continue into
season three Quentin is back to being a
detective and the Commissioner is dead
so I'm expecting everyone to just get
bumped up the ladder and Quentin will
just be in charge of the police force
next season so it'll make it a lot
easier for him to coordinate with team
arrow whenever they do missions so many
big questions that still need to be
answered before the finale but overall
the episode was a solid a everything
from the set design to the acting to the
character development just talking about
the set design first this was such a
huge undertaking with all the extra
debris the cars literally setting the
streets on fire then you have the stunt
work there were a few pauses in the
action but essentially this episode was
just like one continuous fight scene
it's one thing to choreograph a fight
between two people in the small space
but there were multiple fights going on
in scenes across the entire episode I'd
be willing to bet they spent more time
and energy on these last two episodes
than on all the other episodes this
season combined it was totally worth it
really almost all the other comic book
based TV shows are being judged by
arrows example now you know from
character development to set design to
action in my opinion from an acting
standpoint
Laurel Oliver and brother blood tied for
best performance you expect Stephen
Amell to be the best just because he's
the lead actor but Kevin Alejandro
really killed it for his final scenes
and Laurel has really been a
through-line for the call to action that
all the heroes have gotten in the last
couple of episodes but just speaking
about brother Bloods final moments did
you get a Batman vibe from him like
Batman put on his mask to face his fears
I think that was actually a line from
bad
man begins I just love that the
character was clearly Looney Tunes and
Oliver has that moment where he's like
you are [ __ ] kidding yourself if you
think you still get to be mayor after
this so the big things that I'm really
hoping we get to see in the finale are a
continuation to the story involving all
of her son a trailer for the flash TV
show and a really nice teaser for season
3 be sure to let me know though what are
you hoping to see the most and if
there's anything that I didn't include
in the video that you thought was really
important just write it below in the
comments like normal I'm posting my Q&A
tomorrow be sure to subscribe to get
that you can click here to watch it I'll
add an annotation as soon as I post it
and you can click here to watch all my
other arrow season 2 videos so be sure
to catch up before the finale thank you
so much watching I'll see you tomorrow
high fives
you